part of what makes this question
difficult is this so much is abstract
here right it's like there's a cave who
knows what it is
as an N lose what it is okay so there's
just stuff to try and make this harder
and more abstract and more conceptual
for you okay but what they actually ask
you for is not that hard right it's
gonna be X cubed term in here and
there's going to be an x squared term in
there and they'll both have coefficients
right for example they can we did a
question like just simple one like this
that would've been a smart thing to do
okay now if I do this right let's just
give me expand this out right I've got
my one at the front and my coefficients
are gonna be 1 3 3 1 you care with that
okay so I'm just gonna actually like a 1
3 3 1 to stop with okay for the first
term what else do I have hanging around
the coefficient I well yeah nothing I
mean I don't have nothing I have one
cute but that's that's nothing isn't it
right would you have a look at this guy
right I have one less one but I've got a
2x do you see that I've got a 2x in
there are you happy with that here I'm
gonna get two of them and then here I'm
going to get you care with that now I
could just quickly expand this I can
expand this and then b1 plus 6x plus
help me out twice three times four 12 12
x squared 8 plus huge yeah yeah okay so
I could say for instance I could craft
out of this question I could say the
coefficient of x squared is double the
coefficient of x yeah that's all they
really mean they're just talking about
these two numbers okay but they just try
to read you out a little bit and
intimidate you because things here under
okay but I'm going to approach this
question just like I'd approach this one
they're just things I don't know what
they values on okay so what it's not
expanding this guy out
when I start to expand this out because
I don't know how many terms there are
right I actually don't know what these 1
3 3 and 1 are there could be 1 4 6 4 1
or 1 5 10 10 5 1 etc so being that I
don't know what the actual numbers would
be what notation can I use to help me
out I could use I couldn't your
signature add up the whole series right
but I actually want to tease out the
pots I want to know what they are
separately so I'm gonna use this
notation right this is my shorthand way
of writing for some power which term I
want okay so the first term the first
time is just going to have an energy 0
okay
just like before right I'm gonna have a
one term see that how many of them will
I have oh right nothing
okay when I go over to the next term I'm
gonna have em choose one whatever that
might be
and I'm gonna have I'm gonna have some
ones one les'boat ah but now I get this
guy it's time to come in right X okay
how many of them just the one how far do
I need to go I need to get to it I need
to get to the x squared term and the X
cubed term and then I can stop I mean it
goes on for and but I don't know how
many that is okay so now I'm gonna get
up to this guy and how many ones will I
have - two you're probably like why do
you why does he keep writing the ones
because just as easily this number could
have been something else and then you
need the min but so I'm just trying to
pay you for the more complicated words
how many x1k is will I have I'm just
following the pattern right okay
ha there's my x squared term that's
really good and I'm gonna need to go one
more right I'm gonna get in
choose 3 1 n minus 3 xk huge it's a
messy end you happy with that
ok now this is not actually what it's
equal to there are more terms but I
don't need any other terms do I come in
again XO 4 + X - 5 all the way up until
the very last term it just for the sake
of interest 3 n choose n which will
always be one that's the last thing ok
how many ones real I have this quarter
I'll have none left and then I'll have
this guy just hanging on the end right
just like I had three of them here I
have n of them there okay this question
doesn't require that but later question
is mine okay so this is the whole thing
I've got Norman in here
alright now I'll refer to what the
question tells me about the
relationships of these coefficients
right sure here is the coefficient of x
square and it actually does include this
guy as well and here is the coefficient
of x cubed and includes that guy are you
okay with that so I'm gonna take this
slide here directly sorry ways not to
set up your solutions okay I'm gonna
take that guy and I'm gonna write him
out with what I know about the
coefficient of x cute and the
coefficient x squared let's do the
coefficient of x cute I've got and
choose three I guess I'll stop writing
the ones now since I know what they do
I've got the X cube there but I also
have this guy hanging around to you
right how many of them do I have I have
three of them as well right so that's
one over K cute you okay with that
next co-efficient x squared 2 times the
coefficient of x squared so I'll stick
it to there then I start writing my
coefficient 2 1 on K squared okay
take a break right this was hard to get
to right this is an important step is a
mock hammer right wouldn't you look at
this and you look at what you're
required to prove do I look like I'm on
the right track I need I need a
relationship between ends and K's do I
have ends and K's in this line yeah I do
is there any other stuff there that I
need to get rid of well this is just a
numerical algebraic rearranging that I
have to do that's all I really need this
is promising
okay so this is me mentally checking
that I'm on the right track right now
before I start to unpack it what can you
do this might go way way way back and
remember what these are these brackets
what they actually refer to he refers
all this factorial business right that's
the only thing I can really do here okay
apart from these K is I can do some
canceling right so how would you expand
this I'll give you a minute write out
the next line it will take you some time
think carefully about it there's my
definition
oh yeah
isn't just wait which button
okay should we have a go at it so I put
my next line down right all I've really
done is I have evaluated what this NC 3
notation nc2 notation means in terms of
factorials and then I've just got these
guys I've brought them out to plant and
you can see this is like canceling
heaven what's this
okay these are both products right I've
got an N factor over there in factorial
ban right so they just it's just me go
on
you came with that yeah you can see what
I'm doing neat I'm gone what else oh my
god I've got a 3 factorial there and a 2
factorial there right so this is 3 times
2 times 1 and this is 2 times 1 so what
am I gonna get left with I'm going to
get rid of that and the factorial
disappears now the reason why that's
awesome is so I can play exactly the
same trick with this n minus 2 factorial
and the N minus 3 factorial be careful
which number is bigger this one or this
one this one is bigger right cuz say in
100 say this is to the power 100 right
this is gonna be 98 factorial and
that'll be 97 factorial so this is
clearly bigger right this term will have
every single one of these terms in it
plus one more namely n minus 2 so this
guy completely disappears and this
factorial goes okay I think he going
right this K squared over here
and this K cubed over here what shall I
cancel what are we left cancel the K
squared and what are we left over here
okay by the way I can't do that why can
I do that because K is nonzero at least
it better not be otherwise just flip the
table would go okay so Kayla's yesterday
if I can get rid of it all right we are
all right now it's like that'll be
interesting
okay now I've cancelled so very much
okay so what do I have left over on the
left-hand side it looks to me like I've
got one on three things
okay you satisfied with that one on the
right I've got a two on the top and I've
got n minus 2 on the bottom does this
look like I'm going in the right
direction
it sure does like you check that 6 K out
right seeks K equals n minus 2 because I
cross multiplying so just rewrite